[Music]
enriching the Islamic ethos in your
life introducing peace mobile the
solution for
Humanity the quality par xalos Islamic
smartphone 4.63 in LED
screen Slimmer
body premium finish
stylish
design dual SIM 32GB SD card plus 4 GB
internal
memory dual core
processor 5 mapel autofocus camera live
peace tv English Udu and banga over 80
hours of Dr Zakir Nikes videos over 50
authentic Islamic applications
over 100 Islamic
wallpapers over 200 Islamic ringtones
Islamic nasheeds books on Islam and
comparative religion of Dr Zakir n
living life easy and convenient
communicating with technology par
Excellence fostering your innate
relationship with your creator enriching
your life on the Move moments
islamically secured experience the
difference peace peace aine the solution
for
Humanity for inquiries on wholesale and
Retail purchases log on to
www.peace ammunition.com
[Music]